Roger Waters words and writings are
filled with anti-western anti-jewish
rhetoric in his speech
for the ACT to the UN Security Council
he makes more jibes at Israel than he
does proffer actual solutions for the
Ukraine Russia War this has all come
about by the way the reason why Putin
has asked him or the Russian Federation
has asked him is because of an interview
he did with the Berliner Berliner
zeitung earlier this month again this
interview littered with anti-western
Jabs and anti-israel Jabs he he Compares
Israel again to Nazi Germany as if what
Israel is doing is any way comparable to
the slaughter of six million Jews he
says that he would not boy he would
absolutely play in Russia if he could if
there was anyone to boycott for
political reasons apparently it's
America